what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation gonna do a first time watching today
for a movie that I I know literally nothing
about nothing at all called Coraline and I
am joined today by returning co-host Michael
from Omni media Michael how's it going Mikey
I'm running on coffee Greg running on coffee
with Michael um and doing great band a bad
man I'm running on no capping we're gonna
watch this dark movie all I've heard is that
it's an animated movie that's a little bit
darker than people thought let's see whatever
the heck that means ladies and gentlemen if
you can leave a like we would love that very
much also um you can subscribe to our Channel
but also subscribe to omnimedia he does plenty
of reactions all the time dude never sleeps
he's a living vampire it's great he's our
own our own morbius in our lives also full
length to action watch as long as you sync
up with your own copy for Coraline available
for super sexy rejects that's how we met Michael
if you want to collab with us all you got
to do is roll the dice there and see if I
hit you up one day I think we're good to go
let's uh let's get this going are you excited
let's do it let's do it what we're getting
into Coraline Coraline let's go
[Music] Dakota Fanning
Terry Hatcher
I don't know who that is uh yeah you lost
me already
weird I do find dolls fairly unsettling
intro man oh my God this is disturbing well
in the beginning of the movie ah
what is wrong with this cat it's barely alive
[Music] I really like the animation though
I know it's beautiful and this music man this
is the kind of movie I normally zone out to
on my couch this is like I would say like
if you put just put this on while right now
while you're like trying to unwind like the
music would just like put you out man wow
[Music]
holy [__] he dumb pissed off that cat
I'm just looking for an old well know it magic
dowser show me well [Music] whoa what in those
what is happening
foreign
erds or their cats he's not really my cat
of course I do feed him every night and sometimes
they'll come in my window that cat is sick
man yeah where's the secret well you stop
too hard and you'll fall in it
the mushrooms were a clue my grandma she owns
the Pink Palace you won't rented people with
kids what do you mean oh I'm not supposed
to talk about it I'm YB why below that YB
short for why born not my idea of course that's
mean Coraline Jones hmm it's not real scientific
but I heard an ordinary name like Caroline
can lead people to have ordinary expectations
about a person sure
definitely hurt someone why were you born
oh that's mean it's been a little unnecessarily
mean here why because that dowsing Rod of
yours it's poison oak oh no that's awful you
can't just wipe that off nope too late who
knows maybe she's lucky and she doesn't have
get a reaction from it
yeah well today Mom I would have died that's
nice [Laughter] I think it's perfect weather
for gardening no Coraline rain makes mud mud
makes a mess I can't believe it you and Dad
get paid to write about plants and you hate
dirt Coraline some kid left this on the front
porch
huh wow well that's really eerie that's oh
like that look at that man's neck [Music]
why does this guy look like this specific
character design look familiar to me what'd
the boss say
[Music]
[Laughter] this house is 150 years old so
so explore it go out and count all the doors
and windows and write that down on list everything
that's blue just let me work oh she's neglected
[Music]
oh life [Laughter] great thing about this
animation is it really captures movement really
well yeah
in the world end up with your bare hands [Music]
I know this pain I know her this is too relatable
man I'm Coraline [Music] no no no no no no
no [Music] [Laughter] [Music] such a wonderful
ethereal mood to all this what in the world
[Music]
yeah I don't know about that huh there's some
neat shots yeah oh secret tunnel I'm really
[Music] yeah with wallpaper my heart molts
[Music] so many keys
with a button shaped pommel on it
damn you nailed down that one key it they
must have closed this off when they divided
up the house you're kidding and they're so
small we made a deal
you didn't lock it
[Laughter] it's more like slime to me well
it's slime or bedtime fuss pot now What's
it gonna be I think they're trying to poison
me
like that
a quaint little room with that little window
outcrop it's nice yeah that's not for being
a grateful Coraline
[Music]
oh my God yeah nah nah I'm good go through
a Coraline [Music]
yes
oh my gosh she's some alternate reality mom
yikes no geez my mother doesn't have buttons
do you like them I'm your other mother silly
now go tell your other father that supper's
ready
the mitt has a button on it [Music] huh hello
hello Coraline yep nope my father no need
to
what this piano plays me
foreign
they're like human puppets wait can they actually
see though with the button nice ah yes he
assumes
it's the gravy train I could have sworn for
a second that was Tom was the Tank Engine
just because the coloration mango milkshake
what is this world a trauma responds to or
neglect uh I could see that she's getting
everything she wants and the attention and
everything as soon as you're through eating
I thought we'd play a game
in the rain
ah
I better get home to my other mother but I'm
your other mother I think I should get to
bed of course sweetheart it's all made up
it's all made up now there's a mystery
what's shaking baby
interesting dream so wouldn't there be an
another Coraline they've got the bug in the
eyes and all that so I'm wondering if somehow
the doll is the other Coraline but ended up
here and when the doll ends up and hit this
world they end up as a doll
because I have a tater's rash on my um dude
that dad looks like he's decaying viserys
Targaryen over here
somebody else lived there the whole time I
think our mail got mixed up should I leave
it outside or
just go in just like Toby McGuire just go
in
Alan Tudyk
what in the world new cheese samples yeah
very clever using this mix up to sneak my
home and peek at mush what is this Anatomy
I don't know
what
this guy's really disturbing have beat make
you strong that's vadanya got a lie that dude's
like a fat praying mantis
jumping mice mice they are seeing do not go
through little door it's all bricked up sometimes
the mice are a little mixed up [Music] like
he looks like a strung out Dr Robotnik
all right
oh here we go are those dogs real ah sweet
departed Angels couldn't bear the part with
them so we had them stuffed oh you should
have buried them oh your tea leaves dear they'll
tell me your future drink up then go on her
voice sounds really familiar you are intense
table Danger
oh what you're holding it wrong see danger
what see you very peculiar hand I see a giraffe
never wear green in your dressing room acquire
a very tall step ladder and be very very careful
one in the world these are really off-putting
Neighbors
it's YB
this juice played way too much siphon filter
damn it's really cool animation though man
yeah that doll did you make it look like me
oh no I found it that way old is his house
probably come on blue hair my Swampers and
raincoat dang check out slugzilla oh gross
my parents they don't listen to me either
you mind
no oh okay what you are a creepy ass kid I've
never been inside the Pink Palace you're kidding
Grandma kill me I think it's dangerous or
something dangerous that's a common word today
when they were kids Grandma's sister
there's a real mystery of foot here yeah I
know people were like this movie so dark doesn't
seem that dark I bet he's hungry as a pumpkin
by now you mean you're better father
yes it's like manifestation thing it feels
like it because it seems so far it only happens
when she goes to bed too
you know the sound design there
gorgeous yeah I know it's very Illuminating
what in the world
[Music] is that a praying mantis yeah with
wheels it's very expressive this movie
do we have like others of the whole neighborhood
[Music] yeah
hello why were you born
hello oh my God he doesn't talk I thought
you'd like him more if he spoke a little so
I fixed him
what'd you do I like it what no you're right
along YouTube why can't he talk why be so
silent [Laughter]
oh
oh this is welcoming
[Music]
oh my goodness they spelled her name right
you adjusted things really fast Coraline yeah
yeah concerned at all that he was like physically
altered for your pleasure
line
oh
what do the butter knives mean it's like a
world that she can control I don't know puppets
dolls that she can control she's playing pretend
I saw a real Mouse circus not pretend like
the crazy man's in our house maybe they'll
love the new catalog at least they'll love
my chapters wow rude you guys are super neglectful
she really just you know you might have just
nailed it on the head at the very beginning
of the movie Michael is this just sad man
yeah put them back my other mother would get
them oh maybe she should buy all your clothes
maybe she should and then other mother will
kill you and become the real mother the only
mother
what in the hell is this you can't take care
of the fridge had to go food shopping anyway
you want to come along you can pick out something
you like oh like the gloves if things go well
today I promise I'll make it up always say
I'll make it up I'll [__] you I mean it's
got to be hard but at the same time they're
not going a great job keeping a inner headspace
Michael with you and I not being parents I
think we have every right to say what kind
of parents they should be you are correct
trash parents man abusive as hell quit all
of your jobs and just focus on your daughter
[Music]
I don't know there's something that reads
Sinister about this other side it might be
the button eyes and the uh extraction of vocal
that's not quite it that cat's honestly there's
some witchcraft Happening Here think and Miss
forcible have invited you downstairs after
lunch I hope you oh I wonder what they're
probably they're like skinny Jazz versions
of themselves you must be the other cat whoa
the other anything I'm me there's Keith yeah
she hates cat It's gotta keep me up but she
can of course hmm you probably think this
world is a dream come true you're wrong the
other YB told me so what
[Music]
day oh the eyes and the people on the back
are moving oh wow
[Laughter]
oh goodness I could go for Darkness I did
not expect something that's revealing
oh no she's a reverse mermaid now that did
not seem like the ideal world
oh whoa what the hell they are their skinny
selves in there
[Music] and now you're stuck this is such
a strange film I'm mystified by it though
hmm
are you you're creepy I don't know about you
Mom I don't know about my real mom either
one time little thing we need to do what's
that murder modernize butter nice black is
traditional
stay here so sharp you won't feel it how far
is this movie gonna go I don't know man oh
I just need to sleep on things we aren't worried
at all darling soon you'll see things our
way they're a skewed vision of buttons [Music]
fell out of their Coraline [Music] and I won't
be back [Music] what's so bad about getting
some buttons for us no no they seem to be
fine foreign
[Music]
what's happening if you won't even talk to
me I'm gonna find the other Whitey he'll help
me no point he pulled a long face [Music]
oh my god mother controls all just like on
the other side this is like everything everywhere
all at once but nothing you didn't like everything
everywhere I mean on the other side her real
father was all like you know it's it's she's
the boss huh how can you walk away from something
and still come back to it because that's life
[Music]
oh my God
what is happening here I don't like rats at
the
facade
of course chocolate never hurts like one no
I'm okay
oh my God yeah that was not Coco you aren't
my mother apologize at once Coraline no I'll
give you to the count of three no one two
uh what are you doing oh no [Music] it's like
Cruella Deville what is she this is like a
real case of the grass is greener on the other
side then you're there and it's all the same
if not worse don't remember our names but
I remember my true Mommy this is like the
black phone yeah
through the little doll's eyes and saw that
we weren't happy oh my God
you could find out has she taken those two
yes Miss and hidden them find our eyes mistress
and our souls will be free or dead kids
fly me yeah no
hey what's up with his mouth oh wow did he
slice it open did she do this to you oh no
she's making him smile
[Music]
oh oh it is a disgusting hole [Music] thank
you YB
what if she's been gone for like 20 years
oh my Lord that would be terrible your parents
are dead
[Music] no dollar I gave you um my grandma's
real mad says it was her sisters Grandma's
missing sister I think I just met her come
on where are her parents yeah are there a
bunch of other questions
you're crazy [Music] wow
were they abducted or something I mean that's
what I'm thinking what's it for well it might
help they're good for bad things those things
April bad loss bad lost bad lust I like to
think every one of these choices have a meaning
but some of it I think is just really random
this is one of those uh movies like you gotta
you probably have to watch a couple times
let's watch it again right after yes we don't
need to sleep
[Music] oh you gave her the neck brace now
you appreciate them huh to be fair she's just
wanted their attention this entire time anyway
hello how did you get in do you know where
Mom and Dad are
oh you can't now he went from disgustingly
cute oh my God they're hanging in the living
room
what the heck
oh I would not put that cat on the glass
oh my God oh my God
does that have consequences
they were cold because they were under the
bed now they're on fire
you know you're walking right into a trap
she may not play fair but she won't refuse
she's got a thing for games it's sort of a
bit crazy to see in the theaters yeah where
are my parents gosh I have no idea where your
old parents are perhaps they've grown bored
of you and run away to France they weren't
bored of me you stole them oh wow yikes yikes
what has become of him
why don't you have your own key [Music] oh
God why don't we play a game I know you like
them you want to play a game called remove
the buttons from your eyes
my real parents and the eyes of the ghost
children what if you don't find them if I
lose I'll let you sew buttons into my eyes
oh God in each of three wonders I've made
just for you a ghost's eye is Lost In Plain
Sight and for my parents hmm
I don't get it hmm
oh
yikes [Music]
must be it
oh geez this poor man
[Music]
oh tomorrow Papa he was so nice I like how
the mom in both worlds is portrayed as just
awful yeah someone's working through some
stuff
[Music] are you foreign
yeah they're like I actually wrapped up one
of those taffies or whatever
um
what is happening
oh my God they're wrapped up oh my God
no they get stuck they're gonna get stuck
oh maybe oh I know she only cares about this
YB I know is this what you're looking for
uh-huh you think winning game is good team
I'm gonna have great dreams tonight I can
feel it
so easy is he right now I don't know a rat
or a series of rats oh
oh my God Michael you're right
[Music] oh these goddammers these tricky little
bastards this movie's wild man
foreign what does the button symbolize oh
God lost the game
there's still time Coraline [Music] it looked
like you
like you cool cat I
there is so much asked of this Coraline
what the with the realities distorting and
breaking apart we're in The Matrix
[Applause]
only the house is safe that's that's hmm
unless this is just like it's true for all
really did itself going to the foundation
you still need to find your old parents too
bad you won't have this
you cruel-hearted lady [Music]
I already know where you've hidden them they're
behind that door
ah Detroit Zoo you're wrong Coraline she's
so creepy yeah now
no no no I'm [Music] why would you throw the
cat
she's got needle hands the cat's been so helpful
[Music]
foreign
wow holy crap man where are you selfish brat
yikes this is okay it's pretty darn sweet
Ah that's so creepy
yes dead kids
foreign
[Music] [Laughter]
oh wow
that was scary
are they Carline thank God we got a lot to
celebrate you're talking about your Garden
catalog what else [Music]
what's wrong with you idiots bunch of dumbass
parents you should have gotten butter on her
eyes stay here stay there crazy lady
it wasn't a present or a mousetrap I couldn't
tell gloves the 25 gloves this whole thing
was a black mold hallucination
that's hilarious it was all I could think
of
no what a forgiving cat but we still don't
like YB yeah
whoa what in The Starry Night your entire
girl what we were done the key Miss there's
only one and the Belden will find it I gotta
hide this somewhere somewhere she can never
just leave it in the keyhole she would never
say well
oh the spot the the part where YB was showing
her earlier in the movie with the well oh
yeah the well the thing you pointed out
oh my God it's like [__] Freddy man it's
gonna turn into a new nightmare here soon
ah
this is so wild man
[Music] our favorite stalker [Music]
oh my God that would have been so funny if
they just killed off why
nice crazy
that's why we have any idea of what's going
on I don't know man he was all like skeptical
earlier and now he was like let's murder this
sentient hand Grandma showed me this picture
after I called you crazy the sweet ghost girl
the sweet goks girl we can tell her again
we can you know I'm glad you decided to stalk
me
no woman has ever told me that
I I don't quite get to what's a weird ending
hello
Mr was murdered in this house
very specifically to tell you
foreign
wow wow what if I went on a journey there
I was just I was just like zoned out on that
film the whole time
that's so good though so creepy oh wow dude
that was a that was a Trippy ass film what
we got [Music]
stop motion rig ah
that's neat
I I like that laughs
something deeper there going back I'm sure
jerk one all right well that was a a really
vivid imagination down the subconscious corridors
of abuse and neglect and neglect that I did
not think I'd be walking into today before
we filmed we were trying to watch another
movie we couldn't get it to load and then
we're like well I got Coraline on the list
and I was like I don't know anything about
Coraline and from what I've heard about it
it sounds like I really gotta pay attention
and I don't know if my brain could absorb
it and I really enjoyed it uh it was really
haunting and very expressive uh but yeah there's
it's like wow what a what a very thought-provoking
movie that I was I was like warped into and
I I felt like I was just I think it's like
ethereal hypnotic abilities we're sort of
working on me throughout I was like okay yeah
whoa I just I'm kind of like ready to it was
one of those things like I'm ready to close
my eyes and just let my mind just see the
imagery in there I was getting sucked into
this other world but what do you think Michael
did you like it I really did enjoy it man
and like you said like the I think that kind
of surreal otherworldly like state it kind
of puts you in with everything going on with
the visual effects like just the art Direction
the design and all that it's just and then
that that score and it just like it creates
this this mood this vibe that just kind of
like lulls you into this like I almost want
to say false sense of security oh exactly
exactly yeah definitely and oh my Lord man
which is uh which works on the on the themes
of domestic violence you know got to be a
little bit careful with our words but she's
like it it is I keep trying to nail down what
the hell the buttons represent I can't or
like I don't even have a real interpretation
for it um I mean I think it could be just
you know because it's not sewing your eyes
shut like you can still see uh so that's why
I'm like I don't know what it means I've been
trying to figure that out do you have an interpretation
yeah I mean the only thing like even remotely
close but it still doesn't necessarily explain
the buttons itself is like there's this kind
of theme of like because of the neglect that's
going on in the home for her with her parents
having their priorities on everything other
than her yeah at that point like forces her
to kind of like she they just moved this places
to her run down isolated there's a bunch of
weirdos everywhere there's this stalker kid
running around this cat with mange so like
there's this perception of like you know it's
this is we're take at first glance we're taking
everything in as this negative like surroundings
so like and then she gets this idea she goes
to sleep and she thinks of all the things
that she would want to see and want to have
and the house is brighter the garden's full
and Lively and her neighbors aren't as we
they're still weird but they're like not as
off-putting they're more welcoming so it's
like everything is kind of like this
weird warped like perfect version at first
of what she's hoping this place would be with
her family and then so I don't even know what
I'm trying to say at this point yeah I asked
her so there's like this I know but I'm just
like it I mean if I kind of wonder if the
buttons mean something's as basic as you know
because like they talk about the mother the
the other mother uh wanting you know someone
to to love you know if there's something that
as a subject in my life of domestic violence
is is a subject I'm you know know about for
sure you know without going into too many
personal details uh it's it's a subject I'm
very much familiar with and and something
I hold near and dear to my like you know I
look into Charities and [__] and it's
often something with that so um yeah and and
you know like there are those kind of parents
where a lot of the times with like a domestically
violent parent with this type of like gaslighting
and narcissism and self-serving where it's
like this false sense of Allure with with
love but then underneath that is it's it's
all a big manipulation tactic of possession
and if we're looking at the buttons as a symbolic
reasoning for the dolls it's like keeping
the whoever like by her having them putting
them with the button eyes that keeps them
as their their dolls a thing to control like
anything to control so it's like the most
basic thing because I'm like that's what the
movie feels like it's telling me yeah but
I keep writing going like zero like something
deeper about the buttons themselves that I'm
not showing your eyes shut yeah I don't I
don't quite know um but I imagine like I feel
like the former is a part of it but that's
one of the cool things about this film is
like you said it while we were watching it
there's many ways of like revisiting this
would allow one to get to know where it's
going would it'll make it easier to kind of
interpret certain choices or interpret certain
meanings and perhaps pick up other Clues and
whatnot because it doesn't really take the
full like horror direction or or the the true
unveiling of what's going on in the other
world until like close to an hour into the
movie it takes a while before we before we
actually find out for that it's just sort
of this Insidious build to like I knew something
messed up is going on but I don't quite know
what's messed up that's going on so it really
puts you in like Coraline shoes of yeah why
would a nice day here look at this this is
amazing um but then it's not and it's also
like you know a lot of praise and a lot of
feelings of loneliness and wanting to belong
um and in some ways generational trauma of
like that's what the other mom wants and Coraline
is also very lonely and wants uh wants someone
to connect to because like you said neglect
so yeah there's some there's some deeper there's
some deep [__] happening here is what
I'm trying to say yeah I like to go and put
your go on to what you were saying like that
build up like when she's going into that other
world there's this idea of uh like looks can
be deceiving you know everything looked great
but like even for like from the other side
you know sometimes you might look at that
other family or look at that you know other
person in your life whether it be a friend
family member whoever maybe it's like oh man
if only my life was like theirs or whatever
but you have like no idea what's going on
on the back side of that exactly so it's like
what happened there where she's like oh this
is great look my dad's awesome here my mom's
awesome here and then when she goes back the
dad is like literally a meat puppet yeah at
the wheel of this other mom and all that it's
like the things start to kind of show themselves
the cracks start to form the more she's around
it and it's also like she's a life or sucker
and uh yeah like this smothering energy that
will just drain you the eyes are the windows
to the soul that she's clogging that up or
taking that yeah trapping them but that's
another way to doubt it look at it yeah oh
my God I couldn't work my brain
I could make [__] up foreign
and it also taught us a valuable lesson kids
it is okay to be a stalker it's okay to be
a stalker if it leads to you being a hero
in the end every young man's dream is to stuck
and then be rewarded uh that's what I would
want the black cat was cool I mean everything
on like it's easy to look at this film and
want to like kind of deconstruct all its deeper
meanings but I think on like a technical level
it's just it's as outstanding animation like
this is 2009 and it's still so so striking
um like I love the movement because it's a
stop-motion and one of my favorite Parts about
stop motion is is capturing the movement and
the movement is so it that's one of the biggest
alluring parts and I do like that it leans
into this Whimsy eccentricity about it it's
it's a strange film and every regard and like
there's a lot of things I'm just like I don't
I don't even care to try to figure out what
it represents I just think it's weird uh like
the like the tubes imagination yeah the imagination
of it all just kind of creeps in and the way
that it just kind of uh both within the story
and just within the art Direction as a whole
creates this like dreamlike quality of the
whole thing right they're not really you know
Bound by being hyper realistic or anything
like that it allows them to really kind of
free flow and do some really interesting stuff
with the shots the Angles and the expressions
and all kinds of really fun stuff and plus
it's just a fantastic Art House man so like
they knocked out of the park with this one
this I mean it's like some of it I didn't
like like I feel like the the main themes
of what is they're going for I'm picking up
on but there's other things that I'm like
look I don't I don't know what the mice mean
I don't know what the two like creepy theater
ladies have dog audience really means I'm
just like watching it going that's just strange
like that's all I got for you it's it's strange
or I don't know what it means it's just freaking
weird it's all like there's someone much smarter
than myself out there who has decided to do
a whole bunch of research and read the book
to compare to the movies and then go and this
is what it means and I watch it on my first
go around and I'm like I don't know which
is [__] bizarre like that's [__] Dogwood
dog wings and Taffy like I don't I don't care
what it means being stuck in this world or
something like I I don't know why dogs specifically
or bat dogs like it's a really strange thing
snowing gaming like everything probably has
like a very specific purpose yeah well that's
like an Alice in Wonderland Vibe too yeah
always yeah for sure but yeah it was gorgeous
it was gorgeous and scary too it's like pretty
scary at times dude if I if I saw this like
when I was a kid that'd probably be pretty
freaked out I mean there were some freaking
alive man there were Parts in the I was imagining
like what if I was as an adult watching this
in the theaters I'd be like this is pretty
freaking horrifying you know like it escalates
into something that that gets progressively
scarier you know and uh I can't imagine being
a kid watching this like when it's rated PG
and I just I don't know I don't see it I don't
see it man I feel like it'd be about 13. ah
well man it's also very important it's very
unpredictable too and um and and uh yeah so
I'm wanting that sense of belonging yeah I
I thought it was actually kind of beautiful
and creepy you know it was like right wonderful
color palette throughout uh it was awesome
it was so vivid like the entire way through
um and Terry Hatcher was the mom yeah she
did a great job on that um and great Dakota
was Coraline I'm assuming yeah and uh I think
I think Ian McShane was uh the babinsky yeah
yeah yeah yeah I I Heard it Through the voices
yeah
um another thing I think like she was turning
we saw like him riding the mechanical mantis
or whatever and then she was kind of turning
very mantoid at the end and the man and mantises
the females eat the males okay I'm just like
still like making a [__] dude I mean hey
if you're probably right man like I don't
know I don't I'm like I don't know about these
animals to know what the hell they representing
at the end of the day man bare minimum bare
Bode straight forward it's a great story it's
a great story with the the whole like to me
I mean the most obvious correlation is it
is a correlation of like a of a like neglect
is a form of abuse and it is and it is like
a of a big correlation of an abusive household
and whether or not it's uh I mean to me the
movie takes a takes a a choice to be literal
you know instead of taking the choice of is
this in her head is it not in her head to
me it took the choice that no this is not
in her head especially when you got like I
don't know how the book uh plays out obviously
but with uh with YB you know um fighting the
hand at the very end right I want to introduce
grandma and stuff like to me I'm like okay
this is definitely because I was still like
questionable about it uh you know when the
when the parents come out through the broken
snow globe and they're like honey we're home
and they're and they're just disregarding
yeah I'm like okay maybe it's still in court
that could be a coincidence yeah yeah no but
like their food was like all rotted and [__]
uh so I don't know um what but was it uh because
our keys were also still in the car and the
car was still at the house that when that
happened so it's like it played that line
while that's happening in the middle I think
it's fair to say that who knows what's going
on but like by the end of it I agree with
you I think they really kind of like cemented
that yeah all this stuff definitely happened
at the end yeah and I like I I respect rather
taking a choice um in in that regard like
I just like just make a choice and I like
that they made a choice to like I'm gonna
stick with this is this is this really did
happen so especially with her why be happening
and you know a lot of times like kids can
be more open to things that are greater than
you know life like don't be like Thinking
Beyond The Realistic quote unquote right delving
into the imagination and how that imagination
can be more real and attainable for through
the youth eyes I think is a great call and
also just had a great sense of atmosphere
too I gotta point that out it was a one yeah
it was a really this is a hard film to make
like thinking about stop-motion like that
this film must have been a [__] to put
together because yeah this amount of crew
that it had to assemble this and then adapting
Neil gaiman's work I can't imagine is the
easiest thing in the world you know to make
something that's really cohesive unless you
got Neil Gaiman on staff like Sandman was
he uh was he part of this uh because he didn't
say that he wrote it um um book obviously
but right I'm not sure like if he actually
had like a producer's credit or anything of
the sort uh I don't know I don't remember
I just saw that it was based on his book yeah
um well yeah I don't know it's a good question
I don't know I don't know but I like how the
parents didn't learn anything in the end though
yeah I know but she learned to appreciate
them and go it's okay that they kind of ignore
me
neglect is okay it's okay because I went through
there's a much there's something much worse
out there um but you know it's I I I got the
impression rather than telling I got the impression
that it was an adult working through childhood
trauma versus an adult telling kids how to
react to their parents right because you know
like that's often what happens is you know
you might go through some some things that
were traumatic and then when you get older
you start to kind of be pissed off at your
parents for what happened to you and then
you get a little bit older and you're like
well they didn't really realize what they
were doing and they were doing their best
at the end of the day to take care of me and
they still loved me you know and then there's
a lot of things that you learn as an adult
that you're like oh okay I see what all they
were also dealing with while also trying to
deal with me so there's like a level of understanding
that you develop too as you get older exactly
that too exactly which are like which is kind
of what I said earlier in the movie when I
was definitely giving the parents the benefit
of the doubt yeah yeah if they don't do what
they're here to do like there won't be food
on the table so like we used to catch 22 situations
so like I get it it's just like from the point
of view of the kid like that's kind of where
you're they're putting your head space in
with the film at first yeah because even the
way she sometimes is with like other people
and stuff like Coraline you could see sort
of morphing into her mom in some ways yes
and and uh the way she's with especially with
YB it's like I like the one who doesn't talk
you know uh she is she learns to sort of perhaps
because the thing with generational trauma
too is you have to kind of learn to break
that cycle so I could see a version of this
where it is her breaking the cycle while being
a film about wonder and Whimsy and being what
weird you know it says it's it's inventive
man it's creative as [__] it's really
it's really it's really awesome stuff um I
wonder if it was made for 3D because there
were parts of it that felt like it should
have been 3D
it's a little bit around that point where
3D was popping yeah yeah
well we did it man we tried sounding smart
[Laughter] the best we could do is try is
try to pull some [__] out of your ass
and connect it but yeah it was released in
3D it was okay there were shots that looked
like it was there were shots that looked like
it was in 3D um that I was like I wonder uh
so yeah that makes sense fascinating man just
reading some fun IMDb facts here alrighty
well there we go everything on a technical
standpoint from music the sound design to
obviously animation was great some wonderful
voice performances brought to life felt like
they're real performers and um you know I
did a lot like I only really enjoyed two characters
which were the most since Coraline like that
yeah if there's one thing that was kind of
missing for me was there's there's other characters
you're coming around too and I didn't really
care about any of them other than Coraline
and the mom the other mom like there were
the two and the cat I like the cat too uh
like they were the ones I was most I I really
enjoyed being around but the other ones that
well there's always like this sort of distance
with me right you're just like bizarre I don't
really I like I like quiet I mean I'm kind
of a Coraline I like quiet YB I don't really
care for talking and wiping why being like
quiet you know mouth Zone he's mildly endeared
to the father but I'm right there with you
on everything else all the tertiary characters
were just kind of like oh that was they're
weird they were fun to visit for a little
bit they're eccentric but you know I don't
really care about them like they're cutting
down all them at the end like I don't really
I don't it's not really doing anything for
me when they're showing all of them at the
end but hey I'm just happy Coraline's happy
you know all right guys well that's it um
what do you guys think about Coraline do you
like it leave your thoughts down below be
sure to subscribe and leave a like follow
Michael buy omnimedia over on his YouTube
channel where he's doing reactions at the
time of filming this what is the latest things
you've reacted to let me see this let me see
this I'm currently going through Umbrella
Academy For the First Time congratulations
uh if you want more Neil Gaiman I did the
Sandman nice you're doing season two of that
coming on yes we are both doing Chucky Titans
Titans is doing literally you you asked me
and like my brain went blank I was like what
am I
the Midnight Club oh is the Midnight Club
good I haven't seen anything for it I really
yeah the marketing was terrible for this thing
man every time I saw the marketing for it
it was just images of other Mike Flanagan
stuff and I didn't understand I was like is
this just like a recap of his work I don't
know what this is um think of it like it it's
a I don't even know how to describe it it's
anyway it's it's good it was a lot of fun
it's a little more younger skewed um compared
to some of his other previous series at least
but I think it like as far as like the subject
material and all that I think it was pretty
pretty solid but it yeah it's uh I think it
was hoping for a season two but I don't know
if it's gonna get one your Doctor Who reactions
popping there's the yeah what else do you
got here how was the last season of The Walking
Dead now I'm just talking to Michael it is
okay oh they they they're playing with the
hole they dug themselves in two three seasons
ago so bad it's so fun but like there's a
lot of it that just feels missing with everything
that it kind of was outside of their control
at least and it's the last season what are
you gonna do yeah but there's like 18 spin-offs
coming so it's not really done those are still
going uh uh two are still green lit and then
a mini series with Rick the movies that were
planned with Rick are now a limited series
that's stupid instead I feel bad for him I'm
sure he was excited to have a movie it was
supposed to be a Trilogy I think from what
I remember yeah what are you gonna do um all
righty well buddy I will talk with you soon
see a reject Nation bye [Music]